I spent seven hours flying from space to
a planet in Starfield here's what
happened when I actually got there
oh
it was flat we just went right through
it wait but it's still so zero hang on
am I inside Pluto
what happens if I turn around for me if
there is any sign of Pluto behind me
we're inside of Pluto
we're definitely inside of Pluto
no matter how long how long does it now
take to get out of Pluto
do I just live here now so we have
confirmed that things in space off
physically where they say they are I'm
moving
or we can confirm that I'm moving if we
look at something else right is there
anything okay yeah see Sharon is moving
so I am
moving inside Pluto
I can't come into Pluto and not see what
it likes to looks like to get out of
Pluto
that wouldn't be absurd